Scenes can be cut out of movies for any number
of reasons.
Sometimes they grind the plot to a halt, while
other times they clash with the tone of the
rest of the movie.
Often, they’re just totally unnecessary.
These deleted scenes, however, are some of
the greatest ever filmed which makes it even
more of a shame that they ended up on the
cutting room floor.
Arguably the most important and horrifying
scene in Andy Muschietti's [MUH-shee-EH-tee]
adaptation of It is the debut of Pennywise,
Stephen King's unforgettable "Eater of Worlds."
Spawning a thousand memes and a thousand more
nightmares, the moment when Pennywise lures
Georgie Denbrough into the sewers below Derry
is as terrifying as it is instantly memorable,
and it's hard to imagine the situation could
have played out differently.
But it turns out that Muschietti actually
directed a surprise alternate opening for
It which ends in a very different way.
“See you later, bye!”
While this was obviously filmed as a gag,
Muschietti's alternate opening does provoke
some interesting thoughts about the story.
If Georgie had survived Pennywise's attack,
it's entirely possible that the evil demon’s
reign over the town of Derry would have continued
unchallenged.
After all, the murder of Georgie was the beginning
of the end of of his demise even if he didn’t
know it at the time.
When we first meet Steve Rogers in The Avengers,
he’s taking out his frustration and despair
on a punching bag, as memories of his life
during World War II flash through his mind.
But there’s also an entire deleted sequence
which demonstrates just how depressed Cap
has really become.
The scene opens with Steve, alone in his apartment,
watching World War II propaganda films.
After poring through the government files
of his long-gone friends, he briefly considers
calling his old flame Peggy Carter but never
picks up the phone.
Steve then wanders through a city filled with
cell phones and fancy cars, completely lost
in the 21st century, before winding up at
a cafe.
“Ask for her number, you moron.”
He then takes a lonely subway ride to the
boxing gym where he meet him in the actual
film.
It's a shame this sequence was cut from the
movie, since it shows the full extent of Steve's
isolation and makes it a more satisfying victory
when he finally finds his place in the world.
Marvel movie dads are often rotten, and Thanos
has got to be the worst of the bunch.
Even his favorite daughter Gamora has suffered
a fair bit of abuse at his hands but while
their relationship is incredibly twisted,
the two still feel some affection for each
other, and Infinity War did a good job of
exploring their complex dynamic in a short
amount of time.
However, there's one deleted scene that digs
even deeper into their relationship.
It opens in Thanos' throne room, with the
Mad Titan showing his imprisoned daughter
a scene from their past, back when she was
his most trusted assassin.
“By the look of it, you seemed content enough
at the time.”
“I was a prisoner.”
But Gamora explains that that her self-loathing
only started to disappear when she joined
up with the Guardians of the Galaxy.
Even a guilt trip from Thanos isn’t enough
to get her back onside.
“You had a family here, little one - you
just didn’t care what happened to it.”
While the scene isn't exactly necessary to
the story, it does give some color to one
of the movie’s most fascinating relationships.
A deleted scene doesn't need to be long to
be great.
Take this moment from Spider-Man 2, for example.
The scene comes after Peter Parker has given
up on his crime-fighting career, and is finally
ready to live a normal life having thrown
his suit into a garbage can.
Eventually, the suit makes its way to J. Jonah
Jameson.
The Daily Bugle’s cantankerous editor is
thrilled that Spider-Man has called it quits,
but in this deleted scene we learn that maybe
there’s a reason why Jameson dislikes Spidey
so much.
“Pew pew pew.”
Even though this scene is incredibly brief,
it's a hysterical moment that suggests Jameson
might be a bigger Spider-Man fan than he cares
to admit.
The weightlifting sequence is one of the best
moments from M. Night Shyamalan's Unbreakable.
“How much is it, Dad?”
“About 350 pounds.”
It's a triumphant moment for the self-doubting
David, but in one deleted scene he gets an
extra bit of reassurance that he's really
something special.
After impressing his kid, David goes to visit
the weight room at the football stadium where
he works and successfully lifts nearly 500
pounds.
It's a nice comic sting to close the scene,
although, as Shyamalan himself has pointed
out, it was just a bit "redundant" coming
straight after the basement sequence.
But that doesn’t mean it’s not a lot of
fun.
Hannibal Lecter is a stone cold psychopath.
He’s a genuine monster who feeds on others,
both emotionally and literally — but while
serial killers aren't usually big on feelings,
there's a deleted scene from The Silence of
the Lambs that shows Hannibal is actually
capable of empathy.
Locked away in his underworld prison, Hannibal
launches into a monologue about the psychology
behind his fellow killer, Buffalo Bill.
“Our Billy wasn’t born a killer, Clarice.
Oh no, he was made one through years of systematic
abuse.”
Tellingly, Hannibal isn’t speaking in his
usual condescending tone — you can actually
hear the sympathy in his voice.
“Billy’s houses will be very small, with
tiny windows; no flowers no pets no toys,
no sun.”
He ends his impassioned speech with a line
that is both chilling and strangely sad.
"Our Billy wants to be reborn, Clarice.
And he will be reborn.”
Only segments of Hannibal's speech are heard
in the movie’s theatrical cut, but had the
original scene remained intact, it might have
offered audiences a deeper look into Bill’s
twisted mind and a better understanding of
Hannibal Lecter himself.
Captain Quint has got to be one of the greatest
movie characters of all time.
Played by the inimitable Robert Shaw, Quint
is a salty sea dog who loves beer, hates sharks,
and has fun antagonizing "wealthy college
boys."
It soon becomes clear that there's a lot more
going on beneath Quint’s strange exterior,
but early in the film he’s played as a cackling
coot with a bizarre sense of humor.
One deleted scene from Jaws demonstrates just
how odd Quint can be.
Requiring some fishing line that’s strong
enough to catch sharks, he drops by the local
music store to buy some piano wire.
There, he finds a young boy practicing the
clarinet and starts to sing along.
“Bap bap bap bap bap bap bap bap.”
Granted, the scene doesn't really contribute
much to the film and would've done some damage
to the story’s pacing, but it’s a hilarious
performance from Shaw and a welcome chance
to spend some more time with Quint.
One of the defining character traits of Lethal
Weapon’s Martin Riggs is his unflinching
willingness to put himself in harm’s way.
This is a guy who’s always hoping that somebody
will end his lonely life and his desire for
death is made all the clearer in this deleted
scene, where Riggs squares off against a schoolyard
sniper.
Riggs gets a call that there's a gunman firing
at a school, and the SWAT team isn't going
to show up anytime soon.
Naturally, he makes his move.
“Get down get down you're in the line of fire”
When he finally reaches the sniper, he doesn’t
hold back.
Yeah, it's not entirely necessary to the plot,
but don’t pretend it’s not badass.
Few deleted scenes have captured the hearts
of movie lovers quite like the "Jitterbug"
musical number that was cut from The Wizard
of Oz.
Clocking in at six whole minutes, the dance
sequence took five weeks to rehearse and perform,
costing MGM a total of $80,000.
Reports suggest that the scene was ultimately
cut to reduce the film's running time, but
it's also possible that the upbeat nature
of the song simply didn't fit with the story’s
darker elements.
Written by composer Harold Arlen and lyricist
E.Y.
Harburg, the scene was based around a pink
and blue insect that caused its victims to
dance uncontrollably once bitten.
Although the Jitterbug wasn't included in
the movie’s theatrical cut, hints towards
its existence still remain.
“I’ve sent a little insect to take the
fight out of them.”
It just goes to show some things can’t be
disposed of so easily.
Check out one of our newest videos right here.
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.